اهداف في المحيط الهادئ. قائلة
ان تلك المياه لا تخضع لسيادة
المحتجين والشرطة. وزير الدفاع
الامريكي يصل بغداد في زيارة غير
الصين. اعلان حرب وشيكة من كوريا
الشمالية. لغة التهديد والوعيد
وهنا تتحقق اتهامات الرئيس بان
واشنطن وحلفاءها يريدون حصار
برا على غواصة تعمل بالدفع
النووي بحسب بلومبرج. حتى ان
تأتي تصريحات شي جين بينج هذه
بعد تقارير حول قيام رئيسة
منهجي لمواجهة اي تهديدات والعمل
على تحقيق الهدف الاستراتيجي.
الصيني شي جين بينغ اتهامه
للولايات المتحدة وحلفائها
الولايات المتحدة من كل مكان.
حتى اصبح التجسس الصيني هاجسا
وكالة فرانس بريس. واشنطن تحت
انظار بكين. الصين تراقب
لقوات البحرية الملكية
البريطانية رأس حربة القطب
الموقع النرويجي الجديد والمسمى
كامب فايكنج سيكون بمثابة مركز
وبعد هذه الحرب. كشفت عيوب
الدفاع البريطانية وها هي لندن
الطرفين. فهل كان بوتين يذر
الرماد على اعين الرئيس الامريكي
الحرب بثمانية اشهر منح بوتين
هدية خاصة جدا لبايدن عام الفين
عن الاشتباك والمعارك قالت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية ان تسعين اسير
على استعداد لتقديم خدمات وسيطة
من اجل نزع السلاح الكامل
بوتريش انتقل من سوق الغذاء الى
حرب الطاقة؟ معلنا ان المنظمة
اتفاقية الحبوب. لكن امر تمديد
هذا الاتفاق بيد بوتين فهل يقبل
العام ونحن في بدايته. لهذا
التحفيز الذي يلفظ انفاسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
مكارثي دعوة الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
رفضه موكارسي ها هي رئيسة
المفوضية الاوروبية تعوضه بقولها
نورجستريم موضح ان وجود اثر
اوكراني في العملية وفق صحيفة
ومتسائلا كيف يمكن للامريكان
افتراض اي شيء دون تحقيق وفق
بقولهم ان محققين المان حددوا
السفينة التي استخدمت في خط
حملة اعلامية كاذبة منسقة وعلى
لسان متحدث الذي قال ان
معلنة. قضية تفجير خط تعود لتخلط
الاجواء. فهل يظهر المجرم
لوبوذوليا قائلا ان اوكرانيا غير
متورطة في الامر على الاطلاق.
او بريطاني بحسب صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز ليرد كبير مستشاري ميخائيل
جنديين اسرائيليين. خرج ملايين
المتظاهرين في فرنسا للتعبير عن
الولايات المتحدة ولا اليابان.
وبرغم قرارات مجلس الامن التي
صواريخ التي تتخذ من المحيط
الهادئ ميدانا للرماية. الاحداث
محذرة بان بلادها قادرة على
اطلاق المزيد من الصواريخ على
وتحدثت شقيقته كيم يو جونج بل ان
حديثها بدا هذه المرة اكثر وحزما
بقولها ان اسقاط صاروخ تطلقه
بيونج يانج سيعتبر اعلانا للحرب.
تتطاير في شبه الجزيرة الكورية
وغضب بيونج يانج من التحالف
خط النوردستريم العام الماضي
كانوا على الارجح مواطنين من
التي اخذت الاضواء مجددا. حيث
كشف مسئولون امريكيون ان مهاجمي
الروسية. ومن الاراضي الاوكرانية
الى عرض البحر وقضية النوردستريم
على خط المواجهة الصين. حيث اعلن
رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي انطوني
استراليا طلبت شراء مائتين وخمسة
وخمسين صاروخ وفق البنتاجون.
شينغوا الصينية. يأمر شي جين
قياداته بتحسين قدرات الجيش بشكل
بتنفيذ حملة سياسية لتطويق بلاده
واحتوائها وقمعها وفق وكالة
على مختلف المحاور لا سيما في
باخموت وافدي ايفكا وليمان.
للامريكان. وهنا يزداد القلق
الامريكي من استخدام الصين
عندما تحتاج الى قوات قادرة على
القتال في الطقس البارد بحسب
كريستيان. نعم. في صوت عم تسمعي
ربا؟ نعم. نعم نعم في هناك صوت
البانيزي زيارته قريبا الولايات
المتحدة للقاء الرئيس جو بايدن
تعا تعا. ربا علينا. نعم. قالوا
لنا بانه علينا. نعم. ابقي امنة
والتطورات. جنود الاحتلال
يقتحمون مخيم جنين من جديد
ويسقطون ستة شهداء فلسطينيين
لتشتبك معهم المقاومة وتصيب
التوقف يثير الشك لدى بكين بشأن
مضمون الزيارة. لتدخل استراليا
في قمة يتوقع ان يتخللها الاعلان
عن اتفاق ضخم تستحوذ بموجبه كامب
تشتبك مع عرين بفلسطين. الروس
يضربون اوكرانيا في مقتل. بعد
العسكري وفق وول ستريت جورنال.
وماذا بعد يا اصحاب العيون
الضيقة؟ وبمبدأ ضربني باكا
وسيباجني واشتكى وجه الرئيس
تايوان برحلة خارجية تتوقف
خلالها في الولايات المتحدة. هذا
الشمالي بالقرب من روسيا. وهي
وحدة تلجأ اليها المملكة المتحدة
الروسي لاوكرانيا ولتعويض
الاسلحة التي تم تقديمها لكييف
ايضا بحسب بلومبرج. بينما اعلنت
البحرية الملكية البريطانية ان
الفين وواحد وعشرين. لكن
العلاقات تدهورت بعد ذلك بين
الدعم المفتوح من بلاده
لاوكرانيا رفضا قاطعا. لكن ما
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي حشد حتى
الان اثني عشر مليار يورو
دولار عندما التقيا في قمة كانت
مرتقبة بشدة لجنيف في يونيو
الالمانية. وهنا ضربة اخرى نحو
كييف بتصويب امريكي حيث رفض رئيس
الاسبوع المقبل بمحاولة لمعالجة
نقاط الضعف التي كشفها الغزو
وواحد وعشرين. اعطاه صندوق كتابة
مطليا وقلما بقيمة اثني عشر الف
اوكرانيا لافهم اين يوجد شيك على
بياض واين لا يوجد اي انه يرفض
قلته. لا شيكات مفتوحة ولا اسلحة
حسنا لست بحاجة للذهاب الى
رفضهم لمشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد
وشهدت المظاهرات عنف بين
للمنطقة المحيطة بمحطة للطاقة
النووية وفق وكالة تاس. وبعيدا
من القوات الاوكرانية بنهاية
العام الجاري. لقد قالت نهاية
للاسرى بين الطرفين. ومن احداث
الحرب الى ما قبلها وقبل ان تبدأ
تفوح برائحة جريمة هائلة. مضيفا
انهم يريدون تشتيت الانتباه
المقبلة محذرا من خطورة
الاستهانة بقدرات القوات
حرب روسي عادوا من اوكرانيا
بينما اعلنت كييب عودة مائة
استسلام مسبق ام انه مجرد سبق
صحفي الغرب ليجيب الامين العام
الى مدن اخرى في اوكرانيا بحسب
شبكة سي ان ان. فهل هو اعلان
تعتزم الانفاق الدفاعي في
الميزانية التي ستعلن عنها
وثلاثين جنديا اوكرانيا بعد
اطلاق سراحهم في احدث تبادل
الاخيرة. لننتقل الى حرب الغذاء
المثيرة حيث وصل الامين العام
للامم المتحدة انطوني جوتريش الى
اوكرانيا وفق ما صرح به فرحان حق
مساعدات عسكرية الى اوكرانيا ان
الاتحاد يعتزم تدريب ثلاثين الفا
الامريكي الكوري الجنوبي لا
يتوقف. وهذه المرة صمت الزعيم
تحظر تجارب الكورية الشمالية فان
واشنطن لم تجرؤ بعد على اسقاط
لرافعات البضائع في التجسس. حيث
يمكنها نقل معلومات عن الشحن
وكالة بريان نوفوستي. ليزيد
الالمان طين الاوكرانيبيلا
لزيارة اوكرانيا. وقال مكارثي
لنكن واضحين للغاية بشأن ما
المعلومات الاستخباراتية
الامريكية الاخيرة بشأن الهجوم
لغة التحدي وعنفوان الانتصارات
الباهتة اوكرانيا تعود الى الخلف
اوكرانيا او روس او البلدين معا.
ولم يشارك في العملية اي امريكي
سيطرة قواته بشكل كامل على شرق
مدينة باخموت. بينما اعلنت هيئة
ابعد من باخموت وسقوط المدينة
سيجعل الطريق مفتوحا امام الروس
ليخرج الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
غاضبا. ويقول ان روسيا ستذهب الى
نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم وذلك للقاء الرئيس لتمديد
قليلا. هنا طباخ بوتين ورئيس
شركة فاغمر الروسية يعلن عن
لاي مواجهة مع الصين وبكين تحذر.
كوريا الشمالية تطلق تهديدا شديد
مغلقة مع واشنطن لاخذ الغواصات
النووية ومئات الصواريخ استعدادا
الشمالي يقف على حدود روسيا.
والرئيس الصيني يأمر جيش بتحسين
قدراته تحضيرا لمواجهة محتملة مع
الامريكان. واستراليا في قمة
لحلف الناتو ينس تولتنبرج بان
باخموت قد تسقط خلال الايام
اما الرد الروسي فكان اقسى، حيث
رفضت موسكو التقرير ووصفته بانه
للواجهة. واشنطن تحاول النفاذ
بجلدها والصاق التهمة باوكرانيا.
الاركان الاوكرانية على استحياء
بان قواتها تصدت من مائة هجمة
اللهجة للحلفاء. اذا فعلتموها
فهذا اعلان حرب وقوات الكيان
تبدأ الحرب. فما معنى ذلك? بينما
الاسطول البريطاني في القطب
للمقاومة امام روسيا. فلا
تستهينوا ببوتين. وبعد عودة
وموسكو ترد بقوة رئيس البرلمان
الامريكي لكييف لا شيكات مفتوحة
تصدقونني. روسيا ستذهب الى ما هو
ابعد من باخموت واوكرانيا. وما
ولا اسلحة بالمجان بعد اليوم.
وبوتين يرسل هدية لبايدن قبل ان
الحقيقي
هذه الا البداية. هكذا صرخ
زالنسكي والناتو لا مجال
قصف. نعم. نحن نحن عسكرية. يلا
يلا جاية. يلا يلا جاية. انتم لا